I told you last week about this total
scam deal that Donald Trump made to get
Carriere the air conditioning company
air conditioner company to keep a
thousand jobs in Indiana and it was such
an obvious scam initially carrier was
going to move 2,000 jobs to Mexico
Trump bragged that he made a deal to
have them keep a thousand jobs in
Indiana many people not asking the
question of well what about that other
thousand because one thousand is only
half of two thousand art of the
agreement is to just give carrier a
whole bunch of money part of the
agreement is Trump reportedly agreed he
would stop pushing on the 35% tariffs
against companies that move jobs
overseas although it seems maybe Trump
went back on that because today I heard
he is going to be pushing for the 35%
thing who even really knows but the
point was it's so obviously bogus and
rancid crony capitalism because you
can't this is not economic policy and I
think we don't want to belabor that we
talked about that last week this isn't a
policy you can't just give every company
that's thinking of leaving money and
it's also not a free market solution
okay even Sarah Palin even clueless
Sarah Palin realizes that this is
totally crony capitalism she wrote an
op-ed for actually you know what let me
say it differently Sarah Palin's name
appeared as the author of an op-ed on
The Young Conservatives website and
she's calling this deal out she said
quote when government steps in
arbitrarily with individual subsidies
favoring one business over others it
sets inconsistent unfair illogical
precedent meanwhile the invisible hand
that best orchestrates a free people's
free enterprise system gets amputated
then special interests creep in and
melibea manipulate markets Republicans
oppose this remember instead we support
competition on a level playing field
remember because we know special
interest crony capitalism is one big
fail there are also some establishment
conservatives like The Wall Street
Journal editorial board which is
conservative have come out against the
carrier deal arguing that it is not
upholding free-market principles that's
true that it's not uphold
free-market principles but what Sarah
Palin is getting at here is that there's
an even more corrosive a corrosive
aspect which is that crony capitalism
business as usual is continuing under
Donald Trump now question one Pat did
you believe Sarah Palin actually wrote
this or that she put her name on it no
there's there's no way that Sarah Palin
has been reading up on Adam Smith's
Wealth Nations okay no way so it still
means something that she's willing to
put her name on it and I believe it
means that even though it hasn't been
officially announced Sarah Palin learned
she is not going to have a cabinet
position in Donald Trump's
administration that's my interpretation
of her signing her name to this what a
shame she was being considered for a
Secretary of the Interior I'm pretty
sure and I guess it's not gonna happen
she's not jockeying for position anymore
apparently not which actually is a good
thing because that would be really
really bad for the United States of
America Sarah Palin's completely right
though and our friend jenk youger from
the young turks made a comment which was
interesting which he said Trump gave
away some tax breaks to keep the jobs
he's going to get political credit the
fact that this is a bogus way to keep
jobs is not going to be remembered what
Trump's base will remember is Trump kept
the jobs and the details will be lost
that's true and jenk is absolutely right
if other conservatives don't come out
like Sarah Palin has and say whoa whoa
whoa stop the clock this doesn't make as
much sense as we thought so I think that
this could go both ways it's clearly
crony capitalism it is clearly a bogus
deal it is clearly not a way to actually
bolster the economy broadly speaking
nothing has changed big picture about
the business environment in the United
States of America because Trump and
pence offered a particular company some
money to keep half of the jobs they're
planning to bring to another country the
broader economic climate hasn't changed
and what that's why this is a completely
unsustainable way of quote keeping jobs
and again the secondary story here I
wonder who went to Trump and said hey
listen Secretary a-runnin Department of
Veterans Affairs Sarah Palin or
Secretary of the Interior whatever it
was that had been floated for her the
different possible titles really really
bad idea
who
you think could have even gone to trump
and said that I think it could have
actually been someone like Ivanka who
goes listen dad you don't want Sarah
Palin involved with this well I think
it's just evident by the fact that she
was one of the biggest reasons and
taking down John McCain's campaign I
think that alone would do it you would
think that everybody in the Republican
Party would see Sarah Palin is so toxic
after she single-handedly took down John
McCain's campaign in 2008 that they
wouldn't consider having her again but
she showed up on stage and gave that
rambling barely coherent endorsement
although it's hard to tell if it's even
an endorsement Pat because I didn't
understand a lot of the sentences that
she put together but it was at least
framed as an endorsement of Donald Trump
and Trump looking slightly pained like
he had maybe had you know some bad halal
chicken outside of Trump Tower the look
on his face but apparently pained more
by what Sarah Palin was saying and
apparently logic at some point being
injected here and every indication that
Sarah Palin will have no part in the
incoming Donald Trump administration
there's a really good discussion thread
about this exact carrier deal on our
reddit discussion forum I encourage you
to check it out go to david pakman.com
slash reddit that's already DD i-- t
we'll take a quick break and be back
after this